20 points from a bar
[Applause]
[Music]
these capable of just becoming
unstoppable from down there Noah
prosit down at Mozgov space
[Applause]
so bill Vance there's still time here
comes coffers with one from a buzzer
closes down on those who are so well
[Applause]
with blintzes the double one Carmela
[Applause]
Oh
since has bruiser
[Applause]
though who can handle a little bit
[Applause]
fake and the field
[Applause]
it's 11 joki Noah going all the way for
two
this week the rock Noah
[Applause]
- go get some milk with the ball
kids today are Smith
puts it up for the win
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
see the daylight as he crossed over in
the pain you're shooting a basketball
court shooters are really for anyone
Tennessee how it's affecting Tony Parker
time running down just took flight
George Hill took it in the chest win up
a couple more feet with the finish here
in Denver
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what up at your boy Adam left go do you
like that content I know you like that
content hit subscribe for more of it
from Bleacher Report